Class at a particular school had three
divisions
A B and C Division A had 30 boys and 15
girls Division B had 25 boys and 20
girls and Division C had 15 boys and 35
girls To represent the data
diagrammatically we will need to use two times
Graphs One for the number of boys in each
division and another for the number of girls in
each division so we make the x and the y axes
and choose a scale of 1 cm equal to 10
boys on the y
axis so we write 10 to 50  Marking
equal intervals of 10 This covers the data
range for the boys of class A and We have
divisions A B and C on the x
axis Now look at this row The number of boys
in division A is 30 based on the scale we
draw a bar  of length 3 cm for boys of
division a Similarly we draw bars of length
2.5 and 1.5 cm for b and c 2.5 cm
represents 25 boys in division b and 1.5
cm represents 15 boys of division
c Now let's draw the bar graph for the number
of  Girls in each of the divisions we choose the same
scale for the y axis and write a b
and c on the x
axis to represent the number of girls. Let us
use shaded bars to represent 15
girls. We draw a shaded bar of 1.5 cm
for division a.  And Similarly bars of two and
3.5 cm for divisions b and c respectively 2
cm represents 20
girls and 3.5 cm represents 35
girls but do you know that there is another
way in which we could have represented the data
in this table we have looked at joint  Bar
graphs and the bars of two different categories were
placed next to each other for better
comparison but there is another way to do it as the
scale is the same we can just place those
bars on top of this bars division A on A B
on B  And C on C Now We Have Just One B
Graph Such Conditions of Graphs Are Called
Subdivided Bar Graphs How is This
Different from the Joint Bar
Graphs We Can See That This Graph Also
Tells As the Total Number of Students in Each
Division Division A Has Around  45 Students
Division B Has Also Around 45 Students
And Division C Has 50 Students And
Looking At The Different Styles Of Bass It
Helps Us Compare The Number Of Boys And
Girls In One Particular
Division Just By Looking At The Bars You Can Say That
Division A Has  More Number of
Boys as Compared to the Girls in That Division Division
C has More Girls than Boys Which is Why
in a Subdivided Bar Graph It
is Always Important to Write the Legend The
unshaded bars represent the boys and the
shaded bars represent the girls so  The Very
Basic Concept About the Subdivided B
Graph But How Do We Actually Construct
It We'll See That
[Music]
Next